MARLEIGH KERR: I'm Marleigh
Kerr, a sophomore studying
religion and politics,
and it's my honor
to introduce tonight's speaker.
Mr. Robert R. Reilly
is the director
of the Westminster Institute.
He was educated at Georgetown
University, the National Cheng
Shiu University in Taiwan, and
the Claremont Graduate school.
A former US Army tank platoon
leader and former president
of the Intercollegiate
Studies Institute,
Mr. Reilly served as a special
assistant to President Reagan
and later as director
of the Voice of America.
He worked in the George
W. Bush administration
as senior advisor for
information strategy
under the Secretary of
Defense, and he participated
in Operation Iraqi
Freedom as senior advisor
to the Iraqi Ministry
of Information.
He was taught at the
National Defense University
and recently served
as director of Voice
of America for a second time.
He is the author of The
Closing of the Muslim Mind--
How Intellectual Suicide
Created the Modern Islamic
Crisis, and America on Trial--
A Defense of the Founding.
Please join me in welcoming
tonight's speaker, Mr. Robert
R. Reilly.
[APPLAUSE]
ROBERT R. REILLY: Thank
you very much, Marleigh,
for that wonderful introduction.
Well, I want to thank Doug
Jeffrey and Matt Bell,
Kim Allison for all she did in--
sorry, Ellsworth in all the work
she did on the arrangements.
And most of all,
of course, I want
to thank Larry Arnn, my former
classmate at Claremont Graduate
University.
He stipulated that my appearance
here was only on condition
that I not tell any stories
from graduate school when
this kid from Arkansas arrived
with a little hay in his hair,
so I'll keep that promise,
Larry, wherever you are.
By the way, I was very pleased
that Marleigh mentioned
the book, America on Trial--
A Defense of the Founding,
prefaced by Larry Arnn.
Larry told me at
dinner how irritated
he was that some people have
come up to him and said,
you know Bob Reilly?
And he says, no,
Bob Reilly knows me.
[LAUGHTER]
So well, here we go.
I'm afraid this is a
very serious subject that
requires some ponderous
thought, and I
was trying on the flight up
here today from Washington, DC,
to try to cut out some things.
But if I go for too long
and cut into the Q&A period,
Matt has promised that he'll
get the hook and keep me quiet.
So our topic is faith,
reason, and education.
I will concentrate on the
relationship between faith
and reason, which one would
need a very good education
to explore and to
understand properly.
The very differentiation
of faith and reason--
there's something of a
relatively recent provenance
and is uniquely Western.
Ancient tribal
man would not have
understood the distinction.
It was born of the contact
between Greek philosophy
and Christianity.
Only that encounter or
collision, if you will,
generated the concepts
in faith and reason
as two distinct realms.
Tertullian famously
asked, "What has
Athens to do with Jerusalem?"
This question has reverberated
down the centuries.
Nearer to our own time, the
great political philosopher,
Leo Strauss, said that these
two cities, the one representing
philosophy and the
other divine revelation,
each made their own
comprehensive claim
to understanding what
completes man according
to what is highest in him.
He suggested that these claims
are antithetical to each other,
but that neither
can be disproven.
Moreover, he said that
the unresolved tension
between these two
cities was fructifying.
It is what animated
Western civilization
and made its great
achievements possible.
Eric Voegelin thought that
the unresolved tension was
not between these two
cities, but between imminence
and transcendence, and
that reason was just
as much a form of revelation
as revelation itself.
These are two possible answers
to Tertullian's question.
There is not sufficient time
to discuss them in relation
to Islam or Judaism, but
let's consider these questions
in regard to Christianity.
Are faith and reason
headed forever
for a head-on collision
with each other?
Or are they actually in
separate but parallel lanes
headed in the same direction
toward a final destination
in the highest truth?
Do they have nothing
to say to each other,
or can each be understood
better in light of the other?
Do those who say faith has
nothing to do with reason
ignore what faith
itself says of reason?
And is not reason
ineluctably drawn to judge
whether the content of
faith itself is reasonable?
Does it have the
competence to do that?
These are the issues I want
to touch upon this evening.
There's been a lot
of ink and some blood
spilled over these questions.
Henry Cardinal Manning
in the 19th century
said, quote, "All human conflict
is ultimately theological,"
unquote.
Does this mean that people
with different theologies
must kill each other?
For extended periods of
history, the answer was yes.
My god will defeat your
god on the field of battle.
It was often thought that no
society or political order
could cohere unless it was
religiously homogeneous.
This is sometimes referred to
as the theological-political
problem.
That it need not be so has been
demonstrated by the achievement
of the United States.
In any case, the answers
to these questions
will affect the
conduct of our lives
because they concern
the nature of reality,
our ways of knowing it, and
the truth of things, including
the purpose of our lives.
Of course, the
answers will depend
on the content of
what reason reveals
and on what
revelation discloses.
I will touch upon the respective
contributions of these cities
and suggest in what way
they illuminate each other.
I'll also try to sketch out the
consequences of the position
that they are completely
bifurcated and antagonistic.
How is the authority of reason
established in the first place?
Upon what grounds did
Athens claim that the world
is intelligible to our reason?
What makes it apprehensible?
How could Greek philosophy
claim the aptitude
to know the answers
to these things?
From where did its
confidence come
that reason is a
better guide to reality
than, say, the
divination of animal
entrails by the high priest?
Some claim it was
Heraclitus who first grasped
that the universe is
an intelligible whole
and that therefore man is
able to apprehend its order.
How can man do this, and in what
terms can it be articulated?
Heraclitus said the
universe is intelligible
because it is ruled by and
is the product of thought
or wisdom, giving it an
intrinsic rationality.
As far as we know,
Heraclitus and Parmenides
were the first to use the word
"logos" to name this wisdom.
Logos means reason
or word in Greek.
Heraclitus meant that
all things are animated
by a rational principle.
He stated that,
quote, "All things
come to pass in accordance
with this logos," unquote.
If this is true,
then reason's inquiry
into the nature of
reality becomes possible.
The very idea of nature
becomes possible.
Heraclitus said, quote,
"It is the highest virtue
and true wisdom in speaking
and acting to obey nature
that is the common logos.
Therefore, all human
laws are nourished
by this original
divine law," unquote.
It is logos that makes
the world intelligible
to the endeavor of philosophy,
and it is why laws, in turn,
must be reasonable.
As Socrates later
said, quote, "The world
is the product of a mind
which sets everything in order
and produces each individual
thing in the way that
is best for it," unquote.
We can have thoughts
about things that
are the product of thought.
We can also have thoughts
about the thinker,
leading Aristotle to describe
God as thought thinking itself.
The maker is reflected
in the things
he made since they are not made
accidentally, but according
to logos.
Through reason, said Socrates,
man can know what is.
Now, Aristotle said that
what is operates according
to the laws of nature.
He taught that the essence or
nature of a thing is what makes
it what it is and why it is not
and cannot be something else.
In the Politics, he said
that the nature of things
consists in their
end or consummation.
I'm quoting from him now.
"For what each thing is when
its growth is completed,
we call the nature
of that thing,
whether it be a man or a
horse or a family," unquote.
For example, an acorn
develops into an oak tree.
There is no point along
its trajectory of growth
that it will turn into
something other than an oak.
That is because it has the
nature of an oak tree and not
of anything else.
It is inwardly directed
to be an oak tree.
Hence, by nature
and natural law,
Aristotle meant the
principle of development,
which makes any
living thing what
it is and, given the
proper conditions,
what it will become when
it reaches its perfection
or fulfillment.
For Aristotle, quote, "Nature
ever seeks an end," unquote.
He declared, quote, "Nature
does nothing without purpose
or uselessly," unquote.
This end state is its telos,
the reason for which it is.
The telos of the acorn is
a fully mature oak tree.
Philosopher Robert
Sokolowski said, quote,
"The end of a thing
is its perfection.
The nature is what is perfected.
The nature and end of a thing
are normative for that thing.
The end in particular is how
the thing should be," unquote.
The natural law
for each thing is
what allows us to speak
of what it ought to be.
This means that what
is good for a thing are
those things or
actions that assist it
in reaching its perfection.
For example, the right
kind of soil and moisture
are good for the
acorn in reaching
its perfection as an oak tree.
Likewise, those things
that inhibit or prevent
something from reaching
its end are bad for it
as drought or poisoned soil
would be bad for an acorn.
In each case,
Aristotle would refer
to the good things for
the growth of the oak tree
as natural to it and the
bad things for its growth
as unnatural to it.
What is good or
natural over something
is therefore intrinsic
to that thing,
internal to, and
inseparable from it.
It is not imposed from the
outside, nor can it be altered.
Well, what is the
standard we should
use to measure things
regarding man's nature and end?
And how do we discern what is
in accord with it or against it?
Aristotle states,
open quotes, "In order
to find what is natural, we must
look among those things which,
according to nature, are
in a sound condition,
not among those that
are corrupt," unquote.
If you want to know
what a healthy man is,
you don't look at a sick man.
You look at a healthy man.
In Politics, he says, quote,
"Thus, the human being
to be studied is
the one whose state
is best both in body and soul.
In him, this is clear," unquote.
Thus, because we know what a
human being is in the fullest,
we can understand
what a privation is,
including for each
and every part of man.
For example, let's say,
for the sake of argument,
that 20/20 vision is
the best for the eye
and blindness is the worst.
With 20/20 vision, the eye has
reached its complete actuality.
It is perfect as an eye.
It possesses no potential
to see better than it does.
In each case of
imperfection, there's
something missing that
ought to be there.
For instance, the
limb ought to be
able to move in
its full strength.
The ear ought to be able
to hear and the eye to see.
The further a thing is
from its perfection,
the more defective or corrupt,
as Aristotle used the term--
the more corrupt it
is, just as blindness
is the furthest
defect of an eye.
A privation of the good
cannot itself be good.
In fact, as Saint
Augustine said,
evil is a privation of the good.
Now, man alone has the ability
to choose between those acts
or things which are conducive
to his end and those
which are not.
Animals, plants, or
rocks cannot do this.
Only man can act in defiance
of his nature, which
is what defines evil for him.
Since man freely
chooses his behavior,
he is the only one for
whom natural law is moral.
This is why Aristotle
said, quote,
"The moral activities are
human par excellence," unquote.
Therefore, references to
natural law in regard to man
mean not so much the
physical laws or instinct
to which he's subject like
the lower orders of being,
but the moral law which
applies exclusively to him.
Man does not get to fact
fabricate his end or telos.
Human nature is a given.
Its meaning is not located
in man's will or desires,
but in pre-existing
reality, in what is.
Consequently, while man can know
what is good or evil according
to his nature, he does
not have the prerogative
to determine what
is good or evil.
Oughtness is already in
the given nature of things.
Excuse me.
Therefore, man is
morally obliged
to choose the good that will
bring about what ought to be.
Otherwise, he will become
less than fully human
and what he ought not to
be, perhaps something worse
than a beast, as
Aristotle warned.
If everything human must
be measured against it,
what is man's telos?
Aristotle answered, quote,
"Happiness is the highest good,
being a realization and perfect
practice of virtue," unquote.
Having established
the primacy of reason
as the highest human faculty,
Aristotle asked in what way
it served man's end.
He answered that the highest
exercise of man's reason
is contemplation of the
highest good, which is divine.
He wrote, quote, "Contemplation
is the highest form of activity
since the intellect is
the highest thing in us,
and the objects it apprehends
are the highest things
that can be known," unquote.
He said that, quote, "The
activity of God, which
surpasses all others
in blessedness,
must be contemplative,
and of human activities,
therefore, that which
is most akin to this
must be most of the nature
of happiness," unquote.
If man is by nature in
relation to a divine good,
it must mean that he has
within himself some means
of coming to know it.
With his finite mind, man can
somehow apprehend, at least
in part, the infinite.
Though he is not
divine, man must
strive to be godlike through
the exercise of his reason.
Aristotle counseled
that, quote, "We must not
follow those who advise us being
men to think of human things
and being mortal of
mortal things, but must,
so far as we can, make
ourselves immortal
and strain every nerve to live
in accordance with the best
thing in us.
For even if it be small
in bulk, much more
does it in power and worth
surpass everything," unquote.
We see in Aristotle's
account an adumbration
of Thomas Aquinas's definition
of the final and perfect
happiness as,
quote, "nothing else
than the vision of the
divine essence," unquote.
Thus, it was, thanks
to Greek philosophy,
that reason became normative.
For the first time,
instead of dreams,
the entrails of
dismembered birds,
or signs in the
night sky, reason
came to be the arbiter
of right and wrong.
It is through reason,
not from the gods
of the city, tribal mores,
or the spirits of things,
that man can
discern what is just
from what is unjust, what
is good from what is evil,
what is myth from
what is reality.
He can now discern
natural causality
and describe to things
their true causes
rather than assigning magical
properties to everything.
Red dog urine, contrary
to Babylonian belief,
is not actually a causal
factor in producing happiness.
Behaving reasonably or doing
what accords with reason
becomes the standard
of moral behavior
and therefore the
standard of law.
To do what is
unreasonable is wrong.
As Aquinas reflecting
Aristotle would later say,
the essential character of sin
or vice is its irrationality.
However-- I need
another drink of water.
Aristotle's definition
of happiness
set up a major dilemma
of which we must be aware
if we are to understand
the significance
of the contribution
of Christianity.
Both Socrates and
Aristotle admitted
that the attainment of wisdom
was so difficult that few,
if any, could achieve it.
Aristotle said that leisure
is a necessary condition
for the contemplation
of the good.
As only a few possess leisure,
this presents a huge problem.
What's more, even
those with leisure
face nearly insurmountable
obstacles in obtaining wisdom
because human nature,
as Aristotle said,
is in many ways in bondage
so that, open quotes,
"the possession of wisdom
might be justly regarded
as beyond human power," unquote.
This statement seems to be
in tension with Aristotle's
teaching that nature
ever seeks an end,
and always the tendency in
each is towards the same end
and if there is no impediment.
How is it, then, that
in all of nature,
only man's end seems
to be practically
beyond the reach
because of seemingly
insurmountable impediments?
If the possession of wisdom is
the final perfection of man,
how is it that even
in the best regime,
the many will never be wise?
What about the
peasants, workers,
and slaves, who do not have
the possibility of reaching
the height of human attainment
because they have no leisure
to pursue it?
What is the purpose
or end of their lives,
only to support the leisure
of those who do pursue it?
Then most of humanity is left
out, doomed to frustration.
Leo Strauss observed, quote,
"If striving for knowledge
of the eternal truth is
the ultimate end of man,
the man who is merely just
or moral, without being
a philosopher, appears as
a mutilated human being,"
unquote.
As Aquinas would
later say, quote,
"To strive for any end that
cannot be secured is futile,"
unquote.
Therefore, the happiness to
which all men are naturally
ordered as their final
perfection cannot consist
in the happiness
of only a very few.
That would indeed be futile.
Thus, philosophy
raised a question
that it could not answer.
How could man have
a nature whose end
is practically unobtainable?
The very keenness
of this conundrum
made Christian
revelation intelligible
to the Hellenistic world
when it first received it
because it addressed the problem
that man seemed to be made
for something beyond his reach.
Against the preceding Greek
philosophical background,
one can come closer to
realizing the electrifying
effect of the
opening of the Gospel
of John, which was
written in Greek.
The English translation
uses "word" for "logos,"
but it can be rendered
just as well by "reason."
For our purposes here, let
us leave the Greek word
"logos" in the quotation.
Quote, "In the beginning
was the logos, and the logos
was with God.
And the logos was God.
He was in the
beginning with God.
All things were made
through him," unquote.
Revelation confirmed
Heraclitus's intuition
that logos makes the
universe comprehensible
because all things were
made by and through logos.
Logos is not an it, an
intelligible principle,
or a cosmic force, but a who.
This is what John
announces so majestically,
the word incarnate.
The startling thing
about Christianity
is that logos does
not simply remain
as the wisdom behind the world,
but rather enters into it--
logos made flesh--
and dwelt among us.
What if Heraclitus, having
speculated on logos,
met logos walking
through the door?
The face of logos made visible
is the transforming experience
of a Hellenized Christianity or
of a Christianized Hellenism.
The disclosure of
Christ as logos
could not be a clearer
message that revelation
involves reason.
We also know that
creation was made
by way of his divine intellect.
God willed or loved
creation into being,
but it was and is
according to his word.
At the level of
revelation, we now
know why the world is rational,
because God is reason.
God speaks to man with equal
force through his reason
as he does through
divine revelation.
Recall Saint Paul's famous
words to the Romans.
Quote, "For since the
creation of the world,
his invisible attributes
are clearly seen,
his everlasting power, and
also his divinity," unquote.
And does not Saint Peter
urge that Christians,
quote, "be ready
always to satisfy
everyone that asked of you
a reason of the hope which
is in you," unquote?
Early Church father,
Clement of Alexandria,
insisted on the relevance
of reason to faith.
Quote, "Philosophy,
therefore, was a preparation,
paving the way for him who has
perfected in Christ," unquote.
The mid-century second
epistle of Clement,
also known as the recognitions,
spelled out the necessity
of reason to faith.
It's worth hearing at length.
Open quotes, "Do not think that
we say that these things are
only to be received
by faith, but also
that they are to be
asserted by reason.
For indeed, it is not safe to
commit these things to bear
faith without reason
since assuredly,
truth cannot be without reason.
And therefore, he who has
received these things fortified
by reason can never lose them,
whereas he who receives them
without proofs by an assent
to a simple statement of them
can neither keep
them safely, nor is
certain if they are true,
because he too easily believes
also easily yields.
But he who has sought reason
for those things which
he has believed and
received, as though bound
by chains of reason
itself, can never
be torn away or separated
from those things which
he hath believed.
And therefore,
according as any one
is more anxious in demanding
a reason, by so much
will he be the firmer in
preserving his faith."
Excuse me.
Heaven forbid, Saint Augustine
would later exclaim, quote,
"that we should believe in such
a way as not to accept or seek
reasons since we could not even
believe if we did not possess
rational souls," unquote.
He also said, quote,
"Believers are also thinkers.
In believing, they think, and
in thinking, they believe.
If faith does not think,
it is nothing," unquote.
Now, if God is logos,
reason and revelation
are not at an impasse.
A division of
labor defines them.
The first Vatican Council
put the distinction clearly.
There is a two-fold order
of knowledge distinct both
in origin and in object, in
origin because our knowledge
in the one is by natural reason
and in the other by divine
faith, in object because,
besides those things to which
natural reason can attain,
there are proposed to our belief
mysteries hidden in God
which, unless revealed,
cannot be known.
The common objective is the
search for and the apprehension
of the highest things.
In Christianity,
Father James Schall
said, quote, "Revelation
itself has turned to philosophy
precisely to explain more fully
what is revealed," unquote.
Christian revelation confirms
reason in its authority.
At the same time, revelation
has a claim on reason.
A philosophy that
a priori excludes
the possibility of
revelation is a philosophy
that is not true to itself.
On its own terms, philosophy
must remain open to revelation.
Father Schall maintained that
revelation, though it discloses
truths beyond the
ability of philosophy
to arrive at
unassisted, nonetheless
addresses itself
to the same reason
that philosophy considers.
He said revelation articulates
a more clear and defined end
than even the philosopher could
envision by his own powers,
yet the efforts
of the philosopher
to envision this
end were themselves
needed to understand why
revelational answers were
answers to real questions
that did not arise only
from revelation.
Though he had an
inkling of it, Socrates
did not know that there is a
greater gift than philosophy,
but without the
philosophical endeavor,
could man have
come to understand
the overwhelming significance
of this greater gift?
If the puzzle of
man's purpose had not
been posed by Aristotle,
could man have adequately
appreciated the solution to it?
If you haven't
asked the question,
you won't understand the answer.
As mentioned earlier,
Aristotle saw the need
to, so far as we can,
make ourselves immortal
and strain every nerve to live
in accordance with the thing
that is best in us.
Yet he clearly perceived
that only a few with leisure
could even attempt it.
What of the vast
majority of mankind
who are incapable of
the philosophical life?
Christianity solved this dilemma
posed by Aristotle by offering,
as Father Schall
noted, to encompass
a destiny that might include
all men, even nonphilosophers.
This conclusion meant
that the highest things
were intended for more
than just philosophers.
Indeed, resurrection
accomplishes
that final personal
happiness, which
political theory
initially proposes for man
but for which it had no answer.
What Aristotle
could only vaguely
intimate regarding
man's striving
to imitate the divine comes to
startling fruition in Christ's
offer to share his divine
life with each person.
Individual man moves from
paltry insignificance
to inestimable worth.
In the eyes of the world, man
is seen as next to nothing
in the brief span of his life.
Christianity reveals otherwise.
For the first time, the hidden
identity of man is disclosed.
His natural end is superseded by
a supernatural one in which he
partakes of divine life.
Saint John made the
extraordinary statement, quote,
"It does not yet appear
what we shall be,
but we know that when he
appears, we shall be like him.
For we shall see him
as he is," unquote.
The implication is very clear
that man's destiny is actually
to share in God's divine life.
Man's end, then,
is outside history
in personal union with the
transcendent and loving God,
something man could
not dare to have
hoped for, much less imagined,
until God revealed himself
in Christ as
desiring nothing more
than to share his inner
life with his creatures,
to impart to them
his own divinity.
Each person could participate
in the divine order
of salvation as an individual,
not through his participation
as a citizen of his
polis or the mediation
of a semi-divine ruler.
To say that this was a
revolutionary disclosure
is an understatement.
However, the harmonization
of faith and reason
in Christianity was disrupted
in the late Middle Ages
by, among others,
William of Ockham
through his exaggerated
concern for God's omnipotence
and absolute freedom of
will and his detestation
of what he thought was the
contamination of Christianity
by pagan, meaning
Aristotelian, metaphysics.
He challenged the
Thomist teaching
that God's will proceeds from
his divine intellect and not
the other way around.
This is the core issue
of that time and our own.
Aquinas argued that since
God is logos or reason
itself, his, quote, "will
follows upon his intellect,"
unquote.
Reason rules.
Will follows.
The word precedes action.
This was not a new
teaching in Christianity.
Going back to the third century,
Hippolytus said of God, quote,
"He thought of it, the cosmos,
willed it, spoke the word,
and so made it," unquote.
The primacy of
intellect is clear.
The intellect directs the will.
The will then acts in
accord with reason.
Ockham thought that
God's freedom was
compromised by this teaching.
He flipped the relationship
between intellect and will.
God's will now becomes primary,
his intellect subordinate to it
as a mere instrument.
This changes everything.
It is no longer God's knowledge
that constitutes being.
It's his will that does so.
In fact, God knows
because he wills.
Will precedes knowledge.
It is the act that
produces knowledge,
not knowledge that
produces the act.
Will becomes the
ontological principle.
Let's be clear.
Either reason rules
and the will follows,
or will rules and
reason follows.
In the latter
case, reason simply
becomes a tool for the will
to use in however it wishes
to accomplish what it wills.
What's more-- and here
is the key, key point.
It's impossible
intelligently to distinguish
among instances of will on
the basis of will alone.
This was a revolutionary change
with seismic consequences.
Unless the divine intellect is
precedent to the divine will,
logos cannot be imprinted
in creation as its essential
aspect.
The more inscrutable
the divine will,
the more opaque reality
becomes as its product.
As Spanish scholar,
Fernández-Santamaría, wrote,
quote, "Ockham has done
away with the logos,
and all that is
left in God is will,
a will that cannot be bound
or limited by reason-inspired
actions or assumptions of man."
Having expelled from the mind
of God the intelligible world
of Plato, French philosopher
Étienne Gilson said,
Ockham was satisfied that no
intelligibility can be found
in any of God's works.
How could there be order in
nature when there is no nature?
Creation is not
imprinted with reason.
It cannot reflect what
is not there as a result,
there is no rational order
invested in the universe upon
which one can rely, only the
second to second manifestation
of God's will, which he can
change at any moment for no
reason.
Aquinas said that, quote, "The
first cause of the universe
is mind, and that the
last end of the universe
must be the good of
the mind that is truth,
and that in the
contemplation of truth,
man finds the principal
object of wisdom," unquote.
For voluntarists like Ockham,
the first cause of the universe
is will, not mind.
Therefore, the last end of the
universe cannot be the good
of the mind.
The overthrow of the
relationship between reason
and faith is complete.
Man's final end is
no longer rational.
Without an inherent end by
which to judge the goodness
or evil of his actions as
taking him toward or away
from the perfection of
his nature, man is adrift.
He has no natural good
to guide him in reality.
According to
nominalist metaphysics,
acts are intrinsically neither
good or bad except in so far
as God makes them so.
As if in answer to Socrates's
his famous question
in the Euthyphro,
voluntarists like Ockham
say God does not command certain
behavior because it is good.
It's good because
he commands it,
and he can change his
will at any moment.
There is not anything
objective in the character
of acts themselves.
By his command, God could
turn vices into virtues
and, for instance,
require us to commit
adultery or even idolatry.
In this radical view
of God's omnipotence,
he is not only the primary cause
of things but the only cause.
There are no secondary causes
such as cause and effect
in the natural world.
Gravity does not make
objects fall to the Earth.
God does.
Fire does not burn cotton.
One must reject
the natural order
of the universe to protect
God's omnipotence in this view.
God was not to be limited
by any laws of nature's.
Essences are an affront to him.
This loss of intelligibility
provided, some centuries later,
the foundation for David Hume's
famous is-ought distinction
made in the 18th
century or what later
came to be called the
fact-value distinction, which
continues to afflict us today.
This asserts that there
can be no moral guidance
from what exists or what
is to what ought to be.
One cannot derive an ought from
an is or a value from a fact.
This is another consequence of
claiming that nature cannot be
normative because there
are no ends in it,
no telos to guide things to
become what they should be
in their fullest according
to their essences.
In short, there is no
foundation in reality
for what ought to be.
Once one is rid of essences,
there is not an ought in sight.
We are simply left with what is.
Machiavelli would take
great advantage of this.
It is no surprise that
Hume concluded that, quote,
"Reason is and ought only to
be the slave of the passions
and can never pretend
to any other office
than to serve and
obey them," unquote.
Your reason is a slave
to your passions.
Well, it is no great leap from
the voluntarist exaltation
of the will of God to the
voluntarist exaltation
to the will of man.
If God is of a voluntarist,
we become voluntarists.
By "voluntarist," I mean
premised only on will, not
in reason.
After all, if God's intellect
is subordinate to his will,
why should man be any
different in subordinating
his reason to his will?
As a consequence, one gets
to make up one's own values.
Truth is located in the will.
This becomes a very
dangerous teaching
when it is politicized.
If law is no longer
reason, what is it?
Man's law becomes its
own standard, based only
on the will of the ruler,
whether one or many,
predisposed to
nothing but itself.
As Bertrand de
Jouvenel warned, quote,
"The man who finds in
God, before all else,
will and power will be
disposed to the same view
of human government."
40 years ago, German
philosopher Hans Blumenberg
remarked, quote, "When God
becomes nominalism's Deus
absconditus," the
hidden god, the god
of whom we can know nothing
because he's pure will,
"the world loses
its rational base,
and man is left to find
whatever meaning and purpose
he can through his own efforts.
And that leads to the modern
project of self-affirmation
and self-assertion," unquote.
An early manifestation
of this self-assertion
came in the form of Marquis de
Condorcet's book, The Progress
of the Human Mind, which
epitomizes the ambition
of the modern project.
Quote, "My work will prove
by fact and reasoning
that no bounds have been
fixed to the improvement
of the human faculties, that
the perfectability of man
is truly limitless," unquote.
The phrase "the limitless
perfectability of man"
captures the metaphysical
incoherence of modernity.
Limitless perfectability
is an oxymoron.
Anything limitless
is by definition
incapable of perfection.
As we have seen, the
perfection of something
is the fulfillment
of its nature.
The perfectability is without
limits, as Condorcet says.
It means that it loses its
direction because nature
is precisely about limits,
and if no direction exists,
regression is indistinguishable
from progression.
Alexis de Tocqueville wrote
that men of the revolution,
the French Revolution, quote,
"had a robust faith in man's
perfectability and power.
They had no doubt that
they were appointed
to transform the human race.
These sentiments and
passions had become a sort
of new religion," unquote.
The object of faith
in this new religion
changes from God to humanity,
from a God-centered perspective
to one of man's self-sufficiency
or rather his self-creation,
but never to man as
he is, only to man
as he could be or must become.
In the communist
version, Homo sapiens
becomes Homo sovieticus.
Under the Nazi
ideology, man as he is
must be purged of
his racial impurities
to reign as ubermensch, the
over-man or the beyond-man,
who creates and
imposes his own values.
All of this testifies to the
truth of GK Chesterton's quip,
here paraphrased, that the man
who ceases to believe in God
does not believe in nothing.
Rather, he will
believe in anything.
Chesterton also said, quote,
"Just as one generation
could prevent the very
existence of the next generation
by all entering a monastery
or jumping into the sea,
so one set of thinkers
can in some degree
prevent further
thinking by teaching
the next generation
that there's no validity
in any human thought," unquote.
We seem now to have reached
that point of ignorance
because we have had more than
one set of thinkers espousing
this teaching for many and
for more than one generation.
If we don't know what
we are or who we are,
we can self-identify
as anything.
This self-identification is not
the result of knowing oneself
but of willing oneself.
If what one wills is the
principal constituent
of reality, there is no standard
by which one act of the will
can be differentiated from
any other act of the will.
Thus, I have no right
to judge your values,
and you cannot judge mine.
The common good is the casualty.
Therefore, a man can
self-identify as a woman.
However, why can't
I self-identify
as someone who finds
that utterly absurd if I
don't want to be canceled?
We are living in a period
of moral and cultural
self-asphyxiation.
It will end us if we don't
return to reality soon.
Let's transpose the
self identity talk
to an earlier period to
illustrate this absurdity.
The Nazis, who believed
in the primacy of will,
self-identified as racist
haters of Jews and Slavs, whom
they proceeded to
slaughter and enslave.
Did opposition to this arise
because the opponent simply
self-identified as anti-Nazis?
No, it arose among those who
held that all men are created
equal is a universal truth
and that therefore, what
the Nazis were doing
was objectively evil
and must be stopped.
The uncle after whom I
was named gave his life
in order to stop it.
He did not make
that sacrifice so
that people could
self-identify, but so
that the universal truth that
is the true basis of freedom
would be upheld.
Well, what goes first,
faith or reason?
That's very much a
chicken-and-egg kind
of question.
It seems to me that they
both stand or fall together.
Without faith, reason
has shown itself
capable of reasoning
itself out of existence.
Fulton Sheen once
described an intellectual
as someone who's been educated
beyond his intelligence.
Reason without faith
ultimately ends in nihilism.
Without reason, faith becomes
something like Sunni Islam.
Today, there is not
a faith-reason fight.
There is a faith-reason flight.
Our current
condition illustrates
that a society will decline to
the extent that it loses faith,
and that the loss of reason
is concurrent with it.
In Democracy in America, Alexis
de Tocqueville observed, quote,
"Anglo-American civilization
is the result of two distinct
elements, which in other
places have been in frequent
disagreement, but which the
Americans have succeeded
in incorporating to some
extent one with the other
and combining admirably.
I allude to the
spirit of religion
and the spirit of
liberty," unquote.
Can it be any surprise that
as our spirit of religion
has declined, so, too,
has our spirit of liberty?
So we come full circle, if at
times by a circuitous route,
to the question of
the relationship
of faith and reason.
And if you're told that your
faith excludes your reason,
ask how it knows that.
If you're told your
reason exclude your faith,
ask how it could know that.
You need your reason to
understand your faith more
fully, and you need your
faith to open your reason
to what is otherwise beyond it.
Always keep before yourself
your ultimate destination.
Seek the truth.
Recognize and know it.
Live by it.
Abide in it.
That is why we are here.
This is our purpose.
God bless Hillsdale College.
[APPLAUSE]
MARLEIGH KERR: Thank
you, Mr. Reilly.
Mr. Reilly has agreed to sign
copies of his book, America
on Trial-- a Defense
of the Founding,
on the second floor of the
[INAUDIBLE] Lobby following
this session.
We do have time for some
Q&A. If you have a question,
please make your way to one
of the microphones in the side
aisles.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned
the faith-fact-value split,
which is something
we discuss, actually,
quite a bit in the Western
theological tradition core
class, and then
right at the end,
to live and abide by our faith.
Do you have any
suggestions on how
to open up that
conversation with people
who are unwilling to listen
and how to bring that idea back
into our society?
ROBERT R. REILLY:
Well, I mean, this
sounds like a perverse
comment, but thank
heavens for the Nazis.
I mean, you can
always say to them,
ought we to have
opposed the Nazis?
Ought we to have?
Is that a fact, or
is that a value?
Or how would you know
you ought to do that?
There must be some moral
foundation for that.
And the other thing is--
I find this very curious.
No one goes to an eye doctor
and receives a diagnosis
and then says to the doctor,
oh, well, that's what you think.
Or if it's something
serious, maybe they
get a second opinion, but they'd
never say, well, that's just--
I don't think that.
That's just your opinion.
No, why not?
Well, because the
ophthalmologist
or the optometrist knows
what the eye is for.
What's it for?
Well, to see.
And if it's not seeing, it's
suffering from a corruption
and imperfection.
And from his studies,
he would know
wherein that imperfection lies
and may be able to correct it.
That's why you go to him.
The only reason he
knows that is because he
knows the purpose of an eye,
what an eye ought to be.
And we can march
through the human body
and make the same observations.
Except when you get
below the waist,
people say, well, what
could that possibly be for?
Well, let's just experiment
and find-- no, no,
we know just as
much about that as--
the natural moral law rules
that just as much as it
does everything else.
So as people remonstrate
with you, they're saying,
you ought not to.
Well, that's an ought.
Where did they get it?
Probably from an is somewhere.
They just don't understand that
the fact-value distinction is
itself a corruption of reason.
MARLEIGH KERR: We
have time for--
ROBERT R. REILLY:
I'm sure that's
going to win you
a lot of friends.
Just take them
right through that.
MARLEIGH KERR: We have
time for one more question.
ROBERT R. REILLY: I'm
sorry for going on so long,
but actually, I cut this talk.
It would have been in more pain.
Sir.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thanks for being here.
My question was about
discerning what the ultimate end
of something is.
You spoke well from
Aristotle that you determine
what's good based off
of something's end
and to what degree it reaches
that end and to what degree
it corrupts before
it gets to that end.
It seems to me that many
reasonable people disagree
about the end of man, and with
respect to many social issues,
also with respect
to political things,
reasonable people disagree
about what the purpose of man is
and what a good life looks like.
So what does that
bring us to, and how
do we resolve those
reasonable disagreements?
And what does faith have to
say in those disagreements?
ROBERT R. REILLY: Well,
I think what you have
and what you encounter
today more often than not
in such disagreements
is you're talking
to someone who doesn't think
man has any purpose at all.
And therefore, it's
just, he says, she says,
or that's your opinion.
Or you don't have the
right to judge me,
and there's no
basis for judgment,
whereas they would admit
that those ends exist
every time they go to a doctor.
And yet all of a
sudden, they don't
exist when it comes to
a moral issue, which
could be corrupting their soul.
And so do you think anyone would
contest that the end of man
is happiness?
Will they say it's unhappiness?
Now, I don't think you'd
find many people who
wouldn't say that the end of
our nature is to be happy.
They might say we don't
have a nature, just
as people say that the
universe is accidental, right?
How could anything have
a purpose if all of this
happened by accident,
which is the alternative?
If there is no logos, then
everything is accidental,
and then of course,
there are no ends.
There are just accidents.
Now, if you can establish
that that end exists,
like happiness, obtainable
through the life of virtue,
there can be then quite
legitimate and very interesting
arguments about the
means to reach that end.
And often, those
discussions are sort of
on prudential matters, how best
to reach the acknowledged end
of that happiness, which
is the ultimate perfection
of our nature.
The other thing you
know you'll find out
is that there's something
wrong with death.
No one wants-- well, very few
people really want to die,
and we rebel at the
thought of dying.
We rebel at the thought
of not existing.
I remember when my kids were
very young, and one of them--
I told them, where was
I when that picture was
taken of the other kids?
Well, Matthew, you
didn't exist yet.
I had to be.
Well, no, actually, you didn't.
You came into being.
So once you have an
experience of death
in a family or a
loved one, there's
an enormous grievance there.
You know there's something
wrong with death.
Happiness must also
involve immortality,
and that, of course, is what
Socrates argues for, mainly
from justice, that we have to
have immortal souls in order
for perfect justice to be
achieved in the afterlife.
But it also obtains to
the end of happiness.
So there are all kinds
of human experience
that scream out for
this kind of treatment.
No, I guess that didn't--
it's a tough question.
That's a really good question.
Thank you for it.
So I'm happy to talk to anybody
upstairs for the book signing.
If you buy one, I thank you.
My children thank you.
Maybe I can even get
Larry Arnn to thank you.
That would be [INAUDIBLE].
So thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]